so do you think like right now
you know hey all I'm asking for is for
NATO to back off of Ukraine and stop
inviting them NATO is opening the doors
for Ukraine to join NATO
and that's a way of NATO saying yeah
Putin we thought you were strong you're
really not if a small little place like
Ukraine is able to hang with you yeah
and you haven't done anything yet yeah
we are letting Ukraine considering them
joining NATO what do you have to say
about that so then he goes and sits
there as a man running a country called
Russia with a rich history of animosity
towards one country in the world which
is America because philosophically we're
on complete opposite ends at least at
one point before Ronald Reagan comes up
and says Tear Down the Wall etc etc
Gorbachev okay great
do you think Putin's at a point where
it's a turning point where he's got to
make a decision you think he's sitting
there or no he's not there and he's
gonna just sit there and negotiate and
figure out a way to do this and lose
this and allow Ukraine to join NATO I
cannot put myself in Putin's head
I was hoping you could do that
I don't know what his calculations are
what his breaking point is I think it's
amazing the resistance of the ukrainians
I heard Mike Pompeo the former Secretary
of State say the other day that it
doesn't surprise him that Russia hasn't
been able to pull this off he said their
ability the ability of Any Nation to
move hundreds of thousands of forces and
have supply chain and vehicles that work
he said that's a daunting task it's all
it's so hard to pull off that he said it
doesn't surprise me Russia couldn't do
it
um I think Russia is now being seen for
what it is which is absolute overrated
military power they still have nuclear
weapons so so as long as those nuclear
weapons can fly there's a danger and we
have to take it seriously but
the ability to pull off a significant
land invasion
is really really hard unless you drill
all the time train all the time prep all
the time which the United States does
we're one of the few who can do it
um Russia's Hollow you know what uh uh
by the way would you agree that most
people thought Russia would have
destroyed Ukraine yes most people were
not like if it's like a football game
like oh they're going to crush him and
then yeah oh my God what the hell
happened here this was not supposed to
you know Patriots were supposed to beat
the Giants but they came back this is
very weird is it really Ukraine though
or did they kind of to use your sports
analogy they've got a couple All-Stars
on the sidelines that you're helping
them out right it's like a last minute
guy you pull in but I guess okay so
shamatya today is talking to uh uh uh
Lex I think he's talking to Lex he's on
his podcast and the conversation was
about uh America with the interest rates
and what we're doing and Powell and
increasing the rates we can't afford a
war right now because you know money is
so expensive for us right now that we
couldn't finance a war right now you
know where us we're not ready for some
like that how much of that is true like
do you think if something did happen in
America neither to finance a war it
wouldn't be you know they would still do
it versus how much you think rates and a
person like Powell you know he called
them the most powerful man in the world
because him increasing the rate is
preventing America from being on Attack
Mode where you have to kind of take the
step back do you agree with them War
should never ever be about whether we
can or cannot afford it War should only
be about do we have no choice but to
fight it
and if you have no choice but to fight
it then you're gonna fund it
so you just have to get the sequence
right and and it has nothing to do with
money
um
but you know to Donald Trump's credit
Trump's right when he says he was the
one president of the recent note who's
kept us out of wars he ended Wars you
know he gets the credit for destroying
Isis uh other leaders in the Middle East
sharing that credit as well but Trump
stepped up and empowered the military
and sent the signal to the Arab Middle
East fight these suckers take them out
I'm going to have your back as opposed
to President Obama who says you know I
don't we can't attack them
and Trump got it right and then Trump
did keep us out of wars and I also
believe that with the withdrawal from
Afghanistan if Trump were president
the Taliban would not have gotten away
with what they did and Kaba will not
have fallen
Trump's conditions based withdrawal was
valid and I think the Taliban was scared
to death of Donald Trump because he's
irrational people don't know it moves
he's going to make next he took out
solimani in Iran and so people thought
don't mess with Trump nobody thought
that about Biden so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got him in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]